a young guy like a douche bag policy
[Music]
oh [ __ ] get the [ __ ] it's gonna be
[Music]
tonight
so if you're not nothing to do them all
you better steal it [ __ ] zani some
grandpa get some cocktails uncle Joey
and the [ __ ]
I'm coming to your living room you gotta
see the Christ killer right now he's
looking at the edibles on the table he's
thinking about his job or flea podcast
wanna pump tomorrow zippered grenades Oh
exactly
you're in no danger
easily go to the hospital tonight so
it'll be a fun night people
I suggest you [ __ ] hang out because
the church is gonna be on [ __ ] fire
I'm glad that sounds like fun Jean we go
a lot of a bad it's always fun you
excited for this fun
[Music]
what are you [ __ ] nuts it's the
Lord's Day [ __ ] something we showed up
with two guns and an extra box of
bullets you follow me it's that type of
night tonight
you got patron another respectful
[ __ ] night Escobar you got monster
cookies we got all types of [ __ ]
edibles here who gives a [ __ ] eat that
[ __ ] stop your [ __ ] crime we got one
beat tonight if it ain't the [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the mushrooms it's always
something with this book it ain't
nothing there just eat the [ __ ] thing
with TKOs in your heart forever [ __ ]
it's like big dick sing ass that bad for
your health
no here for this we're going to eat
tonight they didn't have no more 200
TKOs so we had to switch it up to some
[ __ ] high bridge just to show these
[ __ ] bad it crawls out of the
box like a [ __ ] like the blob remember
the block
this [ __ ] tastes like [ __ ] COFF COFF
medicine tablets you understand me look
at the fine Jew he's out of training he
didn't want to train this weekend he had
to go to lunch and meet some [ __ ]
weird people and he couldn't even no
edibles so [ __ ] him that's what he gets
wait till he test out patron his
eyeballs in the flight of his head
tonight have you people ever witnessed
an eyeball flying out of that I did 1987
Aspen Colorado as dude was doing blow
for two days the [ __ ] thing that held
his eyeballs a week his [ __ ] ain't gonna
bong it at my house is I bought it the
mirror yes it did I the dom 9-1-1 the
veins and sticking out [ __ ] it we got a
model and we kept snorting bull
that's how we do it jack you got an
injury get the [ __ ] out here you go see
a doctor here we go one more package cuz
that's how we do it on a Sunday night if
you came to see one of these okeydoke
people you follow on podcast that tell
you they do this and they do that they
don't do dick it's just I know you're
sitting on I taught your [ __ ] the
loop with a [ __ ] savages here if you
win the savage hang up right now look at
this [ __ ] flop of death lip by
playing this [ __ ] thing
delicious you understand me
nutritious it's cherry flavored
[Music]
boom that's it it's over no muss no fuss
nobody gets their [ __ ] feelings hurt
for you Pittsburgh [ __ ] I'll
see you Thursday night ready to go bring
up a mentee brother sandwich I'm
[ __ ] blood the whole [ __ ] weekend
how to respect you [ __ ] I'm
ready for you guys
my main man J bish aka to teach making
it [ __ ] happen
I'm happy you guys are here tonight
we're that listen to me there's the
podcast you've been waiting for I don't
give a [ __ ] what you're talking about
are you ready for a bum who set bong hit
let's take this to the next [ __ ]
level tonight Lee you ready for the fun
get of debt it's a little [ __ ] bunking
you're gonna give Lee a patron first
cousins without rock-solid say el patron
is cousins with all red zones they
jumping on it here we go I'm gonna give
you a little only first to warm up the
lungs a little bit look at this little
baby just to get you started but you a
Red Sox shirt on baseball playoffs start
next week I went to the Dodger game
Friday night I had a great time I
witnessed the clinch big [ __ ] deal
I didn't gamble because somebody put a
whammy on my bet no [ __ ] mush over
here I called them they scored a run by
the time you processed the bet nough
said they fell apart let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta warm up the [ __ ] lungs
before you inhale the first bonnet if
you want the full effect you understand
me that's what you learn when you come
to the bong at universities classes but
soon go to Joey Diaz not net for details
that's right
take a no financial aid [ __ ] cash grass
ass was somebody sucking dick and doing
buckets
[Music]
that's the one that's the one poopoo
that's the one Bubba that's the one
that's the one that killed Nixon all the
way all the way let me look there you go
savagery it's a beautiful [ __ ] thing
innit I mean what the [ __ ] was that
that's the weed that killed sink sink
right there let me get the top of this
with you leaking all over the place is
[ __ ] this is the [ __ ] that kills sing
sing sing sings a Chinese dude he's
alright he's [ __ ] crazy here we go
it's that time [ __ ] either you're
in a yeah but I know yet you know what
cuz it's Sunday night it's the Lord's
Day and you can't turn a request for a
bonnet on the Lord's Day understand man
this party started quick
our guests will be at any time we don't
want to be rude you insane this is a
little milder sure there's a hybrid the
exercise there you go
[Music]
Banga college coming to a city near you
1-800 bung hit ball right now and we'll
register early [ __ ] class remember no
financial aid available no nothing cash
only no checks no visa don't show up
here without them blow up with twenty
seven cups I look at this I'm getting
[ __ ] text with hearts I don't even
know these people
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this is the one right
there
but stolen you got that first there you
go there you go that's the one that's
the ones I said hey what the [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with the bondage
you embarrassed do a pile at a party
come uncle Joey's [ __ ] bong at
college 1 8 8 8 monkey understand 1 800
bong get whatever the [ __ ] the numbers
call it you can register right now for
early classes
[Music]
that's a little [ __ ] [ __ ] cloud but
anyway look we were here you understand
me it's a beautiful night to be alive
he'll be right back
[Music]
anyway I'm back [ __ ] I'm back and
I'm black you follow me
our guest is arriving at a great guest
tonight my main man Jimmy Norton
talk about UFC common even little [ __ ]
you want to talk about so I'll see you
guys in 10 minutes youtube.com / c /
Joey D is the place to be don't forget
Pittsburgh Thursday Friday Saturday
improv at Homestead PA I'm [ __ ]
flabbergasted thank you for [ __ ]
donating to my niece and say it there
for Puerto Rico the [ __ ] dams gonna
[ __ ] bust and we'll have problems all
over again don't forget about me
Pittsburgh will be back in ten minutes
Jimmy Norton youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz
it's the place to be I love you
[ __ ] along by heart without you
I have a guts boy you're like whatever
they think I'm a Madonna bean yeah